(uptempo music)
- Thanks so much guys
for meeting me today.
I am so hungover, I had like
eight vodka sodas last night,
maybe nine.
- Oh my god, I know.
I went to this new whiskey bar downtown
and then to an after hours.
I didn't get home 'til
like five in the morning.
- Oh my god you guys,
I met the cutest guy
at the club last night.
It turns out he has a private jet.
We're going to Hawaii next weekend.
- Oh my god, I'm so jealous.
Hannah, anything fun happen with you?
- Oh, actually this morning
I was changing his diaper
and I found a whole blueberry inside.
Like the whole thing.
And I even dug it out, I
like totally dug it out
and saw all the sides of it
and it was perfectly round.
I don't know, I still can't figure it out.
Does anybody want bread?
- Sure.
- You could use some.
(uptempo music)